all right guys donald trump's
um 757 has just landed in winston-salem
salem north carolina we do have a rally
and it looks as though there is no
uh pandemic going on which is very very
interesting we have
rabid trump supporters awaiting the
president
in north carolina fox news is live
right side broadcasting whatever
toxicity that is
is live bloomberg is live and we are
standing by for donald trump and it is
going to be a wild one
only uh seven eight weeks left until
the election actually is it exactly
eight weeks from today is that what's
going on one two
three four five six seven eight
exactly eight weeks to the day
before the presidential election and i
would expect this one to get
very very crazy in fact
the uh twitch gods are expecting this
to be so insane that they have already
launched
a hype train they're not even waiting um
and we see at least one
mask paired with the reverse maga
uh visor which is a look
that i read about um and we have we have
a lot that is going to be going on here
so i'm glad that uh
that you are here welcome if you're
watching on youtube
welcome if you're watching on twitch
welcome if you're watching on facebook
facebook which has been doing really
well
really really well lately from the
standpoint of
viewers chaka seki has already jumped in
with a super chat
send them in this is the day for super
chats
chakaseki says according to trump his
sophisticated friends
showered him with claims of innocence
though they really showered him with
i'm gonna leave the rest of it unread i
think you can imagine
what it probably is yikes yikes
i do have memes i do have images
videos and so many things
keith jacobs says david your mic is
cutting out during your show
do you mean this show i don't know which
show you mean
um but we do have a mic element
and uh i'm trying to figure it out i
don't actually know that it's the
microphone
i i'm i'm using a process of elimination
um to try to figure that out happened
twice today yeah that's uh that's that's
we're gonna try to fix it i'm gonna
switch to a different voice processor
tomorrow see if that deals with it
if not imagine if they sent me a
defective mic
that would be very embarrassing for sure
that's for sure i mean s-h-u-r-e
donna williams says i thought you were
on vacation no that's next week donna
next
week cleo torres says if you must cross
a course cross cow across a crowded cow
crossing
cross the cross course cow across the
crowded cow crossing carefully
that's actually the advice my
grandfather gave me although he gave it
to me in spanish and there's no
alliteration
in spanish which is uh which is
interesting
if my lip sync is off please refresh
that is not an issue
on my end as far as we can tell so
please refresh
if that's the case thanks to kalinas for
subscribing for six months
on twitch with the message six months
my how time flies very much so
a few memes to show you guys oh one
thing yeah people are asking if i got a
bunch of memes
from the instagram picture i showed the
other day i got
almost none um i posted this picture to
my instagram
last week and i thought that there would
be all sorts of
different prepper or doctor memes put
together
i got very few certainly not yet in a
position to show any of them
that's for sure but you can get those in
uh via
my website contact form at
davidpakman.com
and you can find the source image for
this new meme format
on my instagram at david.pacman
i do have some sort of deep fake memes
i'll show you
guys these unfortunately this is
probably going to get me hit with a
copyright issue
say bye bye to monetization because
there is music here
this is me as iron man i like this one
let's see if we can get a better
uh i think this is a better zoom level
for us take a look at this one i think
this is pretty creative take a look
i don't know who did these they're on my
[Applause]
subreddit
yeah anyway okay so that's me as iron
man
and then um sorry just one second
i do need to ban someone on
twitch uh buh-bye there we go
bam hammer has been dropped okay and
then here is me
as conor mcgregor oh my god look at this
uh this is this is me if i were a ufc
fighter i guess check this out
[Music]
[Applause]
that was a crazy night joe rogan's
analysis of my fight was uh really
really something else
so there's those uh we do still have oh
let's make sure we're not missing
anything
no not yet we do still have this new
plasma track this is a good one
today i'm pleased to make a truly
historic announcement in our battle
against the
china virus that will save countless
lives
[Music]
this is the hit of the summer
convalescent flows with strong
antibodies
from the blood of recovered patients to
help treat patients battling a current
infection
[Music]
today convalescence pleased to make a
truly historic announcement in our
battle against the
china virus that will save countless
lives
we provided 48 million dollars to fund
the mayo clinics
anyway you guys get the idea so that is
going to be
very very soon i am going to be adding
drums to that the only reason i haven't
done it already is i'm actually
struggling
to get my recording setup working
correctly on my drums which is very sad
very very sad but that's going to be
happening soon so plasma incoming very
very powerfully i do want to say thank
you to
audra evans who is new member number
one today at joinpackman.com
uh people asking oh people want an
update
as far as subscribers go
listen um it is looking very likely
that we are going to hit a million
youtube subscribers during our vacation
we're on vacation next week and if you
take a look here at socialblade
you can see that we are now slated to
hit 1
million subscribers 13 days from now
on september 22nd now we actually we
will be back already from vacation on
the 22nd
but the thing is we are already at hold
on where are we
we're at 9.90 almost 9.91
and we've been getting 2 000 new
subscribers a day lately
i think it's quite possible we hit like
on tuesday
i really do think so and i've gotten a
bunch of congratulatory messages
do you would you guys like to see i got
a message a congratulations
message from hassan destiny [ __ ] ii
and i guess i could show that one to you
guys let me see here
let me see how i can do this hold on a
second let me get this set up
i don't want to expose hassan's private
messages to me
um but this hassan had a very nice
message we are going to have
a compilation video where we will very
very
um uh it's going to be a beautiful
message it's going to be a beautiful
message to everybody
but here's hassan's contribution for
this compilation video
what's going on david pakman aka david
libman
i just want to congratulate you on the 1
million subscriber marker that you
just reached i know we have our
disagreements on certain issues
but uh i value your voice in the
progressive space
especially in independent media keep
doing you
keep de-radicalizing these nazis
and uh keep moving these neo-liberals
further and further
left towards a social democracy wow
aggressive
i wish you all the success in the future
hope to check in again when you have 10
million subscribers wow
okay and then so it seems like a
painting fell off the wall there at the
last second
uh but a beautiful beautiful message so
that's the message from hassan
and i've there's gonna be like 15 or 16
different
uh friends of the show who will be um
visible in this compilation video which
is going to be really really great
okay a few super chats coming in by the
way
we do need to uh blow out of the water
the new member number
i know that some people are upset that
we've only set a goal of 25.
let's let's not put the cart before the
horse okay i know we got to 67 yesterday
but we haven't even gotten to two you
know you don't um
a journey of a thousand miles starts
with one step i think is the way i would
apply everybody relax
okay let's go through some super chats
amber says thank you for doing what you
do david thank you
crazy cat lady says you rock david
stubbs the wolf says hey david you need
to do a show on mitch mcconnell
that is a race almost as important as
trump biden yabbitt says plea
please comment on the biden campaigns
welcoming the endorphin endorsement of
flint poison or rick snyder michiganders
are
livid sherry nelke says david thank you
for translating trumpies for me i can't
do it without you
joseph jepson says david what is agit
trash and how do you spell it okay
so it's not a-d-j-i-t that i like that
but it's not that so
you know agit prop a-a-g-i-t like to
agitate
agit trash is really poorly done agit
prop
that's the word a shaner says i've been
torturing myself with trump hillary
debates from 16 i know biden has to do
it but trump will just do high school
insults the whole time
yeah basically tristan macappen
says i think whether he wins or loses he
will instruct gun nuts to attack the
other side what do you think
i worry that that is the case i worry
that that is the case
the price so drama says hey david
question is he landing somewhere outside
the us like in a country
where covet isn't a thing if not wtf
are 58 000 people doing there yes they
are acting like there's no
um like there's no a pandemic it's
absolutely bizarre
i have to say a huge thank you to
pair tieren who is climbing in
with a record 5000
swedish kroner super chat this matches
the largest
super chat we've ever had uh
currency exchange pending but roughly
butte pair thank you paris says hi david
i
don't want to talk politics for a while
mental holiday
i hope you rest on your time off enjoy
your near and dear
take this pocket change pocket change
isn't that like 500
and use it only for good food and other
pleasures
not one cent on work related thingies
lots of people love you in sweden and
all over the world
wow pair we love you at the show
you've been a supporter for a long time
social democracy clearly
functioning beautifully and um
i i really appreciate your support 5000
swedish kroner is a very uh very
generous
level of support and i appreciate that
and good i don't know if paris saying
that he's acknowledging my upcoming
vacation
or paris saying he's going on vacation
or both
but it doesn't matter it doesn't matter
i appreciate that pair
thank you very very much thank you to
face plant cagers for subscribing on
twitch with the message david
thank you for five months i couldn't
have done it without you
also thanks to dnk gg
and gazer piglop gazer piglop
who have subscribed hex on x
1658 has subscribed uh very much
appreciate that
is music going let's see
yeah okay we're gonna wait on that
a little bit uh as many of you know
any number of copyright issues i hope
eventually our view will not be
obstructed by
other camera people that would be really
weird if it were
ms smith oh hold on i missed a couple
beyond natural says good job david thank
you
bread ledbetter sorry no brett ledbetter
georgia senate race what are your
thoughts tomorrow
check out my video coming up about that
tomorrow
ms smith says should do a rolling
sidecar dance to plasma
once you hit 1 million also thanks for
what you do that's an idea ms smith
kelemens says i wonder how many q anon
supporters are there
what's your spanish channel named i
don't have a spanish channel
need to show my older fam you're my
south american liberal comrade no i
don't have a spanish language channel
but i will be releasing a spanish
language interview during our vacation
it'll be subtitled so everybody can
understand it
well everybody who speaks english i
guess
thanks to patrick beale who is new
member number two
today at joinedpakman.com tugboat
mcguire
is new member number three today at
joinpakman.com i very much appreciate
that
it would be great if we had a better
angle in terms of what was going on uh
here's one this one is not so good
uh oh here is donald trump why can't fox
news put together some better kind of
angle it's really weird i'm sure they'll
get it going really soon
let's see if the white house feed is
live
uh white house white house feed still
not live
all right well we'll keep it here for
now eventually i think things will look
right
also thank you to ralph garcia who's new
member number four
listen i i'm not going to spend a ton of
time on this because we have so many
important things going on oh my god mark
meadows is with trump that's sick
that is toxic mark meadows is so vile
really really horrible horrible person
as trump walks around here we're going
to get better video here
eventually guys uh it looks like donald
trump is coming in this direction on the
f
there he is where is he
i'm sure we'll notice him because of his
skin color
he's somewhere in there okay i don't
want to spend a lot of time on this
but i mentioned this yesterday people
reacted very strongly to it
this program and the future of this
program is very much up to you
okay we're mostly funded by viewers who
sign up at joinpakman.com if you don't
like me don't do it okay
if you don't value the show don't do it
if you're down to your last couple
dollars don't do it because the show is
for everybody
but if a dollar eighty a month is
something you can do
grab a membership at joinpacman.com i'm
asking you this is my pitch i'm asking
you to do it
the coupon code above my head 2020 now
will
instantly i mean it's instant it'll just
chop 66
off of the price of a membership it'll
drop it to two bucks a month
or if you prepay for the year uh it'll
be only a dollar eighty
and i will do my best to thank everybody
who signs up like for example allison
james just signed up
and she is new member number five um and
when i say it's our primary funding
source you know we do
we're doing health care we're doing
gowns we're doing schwabs
sorry no those last two things we're not
doing for i'm not giving my employees
any schwabs
but uh you know i try to be a good boss
we try to do
do the right things and the membership
is our primary funding source so i do
appreciate everybody who signs up
as we await another corona rally
with donald trump it actually seems like
these people here
are wearing masks by and large let's see
what's going on
okay so music is still going we are
eventually going to need a little bit of
a volume boost i can tell
um here's trump we've got a lot of
different angles
the fist pump moment is happening we're
going to hear from trump
very very soon um super chats continue
to come in
alan mitchell is watching from aberdeen
in scotland i watch all your live
streams keep up the good
work dave it must be what around
midnight there i believe you guys are
plus five
from east coast uh chakaseki says
speech buzzword predictions number of
tvs in air force one
soup reference windmills plasma
seth feffehide blowing up mount rushmore
sleepy joe i think we will get all of
those i don't know if we will hear trump
say
uh phefcephahide today i don't know that
we're going to get that one
thanks to aaron nance for subscribing
for
12 months let's get to the president
great honor to be
in north carolina we had great great
luck and great
people back in i said north carolina
and i'm thrilled to be in winston-salem
with thousands of loyal hard-working
slurring already great people great
people
i don't know how many people here but
there's a lot people
we said let's keep it down they didn't
do too good a job but that's good right
that's good now these crowds i tell you
it's beyond what we had in terms of
enthusiasm beyond what we had four years
ago in 2016
right and that was a record enthusiasm
we are
breaking that record by a lot this is
the most important election we've ever
had
56 days from now we're going to win
north carolina we're going to win
four more years in the white house okay
this is a choice and i must say this is
a choice for many many decades i don't
think you've had a bigger difference and
maybe you've never had a bigger
difference this is
the american dream and the other i don't
want to say it because i'll get myself
in trouble with the fake news back there
but the other is a basic disaster for
our country joe biden devoted his career
to offshoring your jobs throwing open
your borders
dragging us into endless foreign wars
along with some of his other friends
and surrendering our children's future
to countries like
china china
remember this very simple to remember if
biden wins
china wins it's as simple as that
[Applause]
i would go further i think if biden wins
everybody wins
a situation where we built the greatest
economy in the history of the world and
we're going to do it again forced to
close it because of the china plague
that came in
[Applause]
and now we've opened it and by the way
your state should be open
your state should be open he's got like
4 000 people there isn't the state open
it looks pretty damn open to me
any governor that does that and even if
you look statistically
it's you it's michigan it's a couple of
others they're closed
new york look look what they're doing in
new york what they're doing to our
beautiful new yorker
so sad but you just take a look at
what's going on in
north carolina they want to open they
want to open they want to open in
michigan so badly what's closed in north
carolina
they want to have their schools open and
it's a shame what's going on and i'll
tell you what
on november 4th every one of those
states will be open they're doing it for
political reasons
no they're doing it for political
reasons they think by hurting the
economy by keeping all these store
owners and all these people that
work in shops and stores and
buildings offices they think by keeping
them and hurting them
you're hurting the economy our economy
is doing phenomenally well
and it's not only is it a v it's a super
v you see what's happened
right we just had a jobs number come out
1.4 million
it's down to 8.4 percent
nobody thought that 8.4
so we had the greatest economy we closed
it up and now we're opening it up and
your state should go with it we're
opening it up
and we will have a great third quarter
it's going to be announced by the way
just before the election
i am worried we're gonna have a great
third quarter very worried unbelievable
retail numbers unbelievable numbers all
over
and this is that super v but next year
is going to be
one of the greatest years in the history
of our country economically
and hopefully if he's gone right
unless the wrong person gets in and
quadruples everybody's taxes in which
case
you will see a depression the likes of
which you haven't seen
and remember this if biden wins the
violent mobs you see these mobs all over
the place
people they're biting states cities
they're democrat states
if they win the mobs when you see these
guys they go around saying yeah i want
you a meal
give me that food give me the a woman
sitting there
she wants to eat and they come they grab
her food they grab her drink
nobody's ever seen stuff like this this
is all that ideology
we're not going to let it happen we're
not going to let it happen
and you know in portland you see what
happened last night they arrested over
50 people the first time we said
either do it or we're going in we're
going to have to be rendering
let us go in we're saying i spoke to the
governor of
oregon the other day let us go in i said
let us go in
oregon we'll straighten it out in less
than a half an hour
now the u.s marshals did go in to take
care of that one guy who killed somebody
you saw that
he killed a young man in the middle of
the street violently he had other
charges against him
and i put out when is he going to be
arrested
and they went in about 15 minutes later
what a hero and i'll tell you what our
federal government is so ready to go all
they have to do is call us it'll all be
solved very quickly
they have to call us call us
but all of these places are democrat run
places
radical left-run places they don't know
what the hell they're doing
if biden wins the right country run by a
republican right now
he said the other day well you know if i
win that doesn't mean that's going to
stop
he doesn't he will never stop if they
win
it's not going to happen hopefully but
if because this is not like a second
place crowd let's face it
and are you seeing like third place are
you seeing the
are you seeing all the poll numbers are
coming up that's why he left finally he
left his basement he said we got
problems
i don't think he knows that but the
people that manage him know it they
understand it so trump may win but right
now biden's lead is two and a half times
what hillary's was on september 8
2016 just facts you know it could change
the future
belongs to america not to china and
other countries
because if we win america wins you know
that you've seen that you've seen what
we've done
not exactly over the last three and a
half years we've secured america's
borders
fixed our broken trade america wins with
trump we're not allowed in almost any
countries and if he gets another four
years we won't be allowed for another
four years
we built the awesome power of the united
states military
obliterated the isis caliphate 100
in fact i got it down to 98 remember a
year and a half ago i got it down to 98
and they all said no no
it's got to be a hundred i said somebody
else could finish we want to get home
they said no you got to finish it so we
took another two months we finished it
and we're bringing them home we're
bringing them home
these great great warriors
but people don't like it when i say that
secured american energy independence and
built the greatest economy
in the history of the world and now we
are very simply we're doing it again
and we're on track to have as i said the
best year we've ever had next year you
just normal diarrhea
an ink block you know you just had the
best year of the history of your state
last year
we've been saying that to every state
have you guys noticed a million
jobs in the last four months next year
will be the single greatest economic
year in the history of our country and
probably in the history of your state
if your governor ever opens up but
hopefully you're gonna have dan forest
you're not gonna have to worry about it
but if sleepy joe biden takes power
the economy will collapse he won't even
know the difference how's the economy
not good so we're at a depression i know
we are what's that
joe biden has spent 47 years shipping
north carolina jobs
when trump flops during the debates the
biden dementia stuff's not gonna go so
well
four years bringing jobs back to our
country we never had so many jobs
we're up to 160 million
jobs we were never anywhere close we got
up to 160 million
remember that's the labor participation
rate conundrum which is as the
population grows the number of people
employed grows and the number of people
not employed grows as a percentage
remaining equal because of the raw
numbers you know you guys you guys know
that i mean i don't even know
extremists that have no idea what
they're doing
to burn down buildings or take control
of government
set fire to a whole country you know
when they started knocking down
the monuments and statues a few months
ago right i signed a very strong
executive order you want to knock him
down that's fine but you go to jail for
10 years
it was amazing
no charges no due process amazing jail
how'd that stop
and then they said well we'll do it
easily we'll do it through the process
because you know they don't want to
spend 10 years
you know they'd look at it they'd say
not worth it
10 years is too much but the d.c
committee did you see about that
they want to change the name of the
washington monument they want to get rid
of the lincoln monument
jefferson monument now we're talking the
big stuff
they finally hit the big time took them
a while to get there but i said that was
going to happen
don't worry about it you don't have a
thing to worry about if our foreign
adversaries were devising a scheme to
[ __ ] america
they could hardly do better than the
biden kamala harris kamala
remember kamala she started at 15 she
was supposed to win
problem was she went from 15 to 14 to 12
to 10. trump correctly identifying that
kamala harris
did not come in first in the primary and
that led to her
being the vp running mate rather than
the nominee
she could never be the first woman
president she could ever be
that would be an insult to our country
what
biden wants to impose a four trillion
dollar tax hike
a ban on american energy eliminate
america's borders confiscate your guns
he wants to get rid of your second
amendment
a point that's a big one
of course biden couldn't get rid of the
second amendment if you wanted being
very pro-crime
judges but they want to destroy your
suburbs he wanted
you know that you know the rule the
regulation that i just terminated they
want to build low-income projects in the
suburbs they've been doing it they've
been destroying suburbs
so all that trump terminated is
something that says that localities
should be
looking at the racial impact of their
housing policy
that's all it said trump's lying right
now shocked
no they said women don't and then we did
great with women and remember that great
was that one of the greatest evenings
ever
four years ago that was one of the
greatest but one of the things they did
first of all we did much better now
we're doing really well
african-american vote much better
hispanic vote much better where's his
african-americans
he did better with african-americans
that we thought he did better with
hispanic than we thought
he did better with asians than we
thought he did really well with women
what's this all about you know ladies
and gentlemen
what was he talking about
and they said donald trump is projected
the winner
of 2016. you remember that evening was
that the craziest
what an evening that was the craziest
thing and they thought
i think they didn't think it but i'll
tell you what anything we had then we
have much more now
right they don't understand they do
understand it they do
right they understand it look at that
beautiful dress
and she wears that dress right through
the middle of hollywood and everyone
says
thank you very much what on earth is
wrong this is crazy
but they want to indoctrinate your
children and implement a ruinous
shutdown of the united states economy
again
biden said the other day well if the
experts told me we're not shutting it
down again we don't have to we learned
about
trump defiantly will not listen to
experts
people don't realize we save millions of
lives and hundreds of thousands of lives
by not letting china we put a ban on
china heavily infected
he saved millions of lives and then he
saved hundreds of thousands
the right thing i have to admit it's
clear why both china and the flag
burning rioters
want biden to win they know his policies
will
be the downfall of america and they know
my policies will lift america
to new heights of national greatness
like we've never seen before that's
what's happening
that's what's happening
and never forget they're coming after me
because i'm fighting for you there's a
lot of people
and they do come after me too much
winning
they do come after me they have more
things to say about me every day at
something they said
you don't see the plane where it is sir
would you like to take the car
and say why i'm saying what well i heard
you had a limp i do
i don't know about a limp i don't have a
look hey someday i'm gonna have a limp
i'll let you know when you'll see it
no they make this stuff up they make it
up they make stuff
is he going to do mini strokes they give
a phony deal out
they did it two days ago with the
military there's nobody loves the
military more than me
so they make they make
you know i was very lucky though i had
15 incredible american patriots that
came by and they said
he never said that we were they were
there they were there
but they make up stories horrible
stories many many
hey look look at last time the uh
fake dirty dossier it was all made up
and frankly if the shoe was on the other
foot
right if it was on the other foot you'd
have
many people 20 25 people right now
in jail for two years and they'd be
there for
50 years because they got caught spying
on our campaign wait they'd be there two
years or 50 years
whatever else you want to call it and
it's a disgrace
that has taken this law it's a disgrace
but it's taken this long
and let me just tell you a little secret
obama got caught and so did sleepy joe
biden they got caught
no one in the crowd saying what law was
broken again what law was broken
but biden is sitting in the room saying
why don't you use the logan act on
general flynn look at general flynn what
he's going through for years
if that were ever reversed i'm telling
you you'd have many people in jail for
many many years and it would have
started two years ago
it's a disgrace but let's see what
happens biden's a globalist sellout
who spent his career laying waste to
american communities
and you know he talks about like well
he's going to do this who's going to he
doesn't have any idea he has no clue
he's going to do this
he's been there for 47 years
and you know he just really left you
know he left three and a half four years
ago right
so he just left but he's been there for
47 years i'm going to do this
you know after 47 years he's had a
change of heart
this is the craziest election this is
the cri look
somebody said what's the difference
between crooked hillary clinton and slow
joe
so the difference is the following she's
meaner
probably not as nice i don't know you
can't get any worse than her
but the big difference is she's smarter
than he is okay
he's a nicer person but he's not smart
he never was not in prime time and
certainly not now
the washington vultures ripped apart our
towns
in exchange for the the jarring nature
of him going from his
free association back into the prompter
is is
interesting radical left you know that
with crazy bernie and everyone
and by the way you know who's further
left than crazy bernie
kamala kamala
what's with that pronunciation anybody
is that is that xenophobic in some way
i'm guessing it is right
sort of interesting that they picked her
because in theory they should be able to
win california i don't know maybe we'll
make a play for that one too
i'd focus on dexter's if i were him but
they picked somebody from california
i don't i don't quite get it but you
always pick somebody that's hot that's
going up in the polls right
going up hot frankly i'm not sure i
don't think i've ever said this but
probably hillary should have picked
bernie sanders to
be her running mate right because you
know as crazy as it sounds he was hot
he gave her a hell of a fight breaking a
lot of people think he won
trump says bernie one thing about
bernie's the greatest loser i've ever
seen because
look any children here no not too many
but they've heard it before
he got screwed four years ago when he
got screwed again
biden got the nomination right he got
the nomination is this a medical event
would have sat back and of elizabeth
warren pocahontas you remember
pocahontas
right she finally faded she faded badly
but if she would have dropped out on
super tuesday prior to super tuesday
bernie would have been the nominee
unclear and i don't know who i'd rather
run against one is
super left the other ones had to become
super left one is competent the other
one is only half competent now
and heading south he's half competent
and heading south rapidly but the
globalists and the leftists make
natural partners because they're united
by their contempt
for the american middle class that
sounds like a stephen miller line
powerful corporations and far left
politicians have both sided with radical
demonstrated over
if you look at that it's over the law
abiding
areas that we have you know republican
cities and towns are doing great
we're doing great and we don't have
crime and we don't have this violence
chicago over the weekend many people
killed
many people shot shot they're actually
shot
and killed new york the same thing new
york's gone through the roof
they're up 300 in certain categories
and you say what's happening we want to
send them in so badly
joe biden and his party spent the entire
summer cheering on the rioters rampaging
through democrat-run cities falsely
labeling them as peaceful protesters and
you know we call you peaceful protesters
you know why
because they have rules in these
democrat-run states
that if you're campaigning you can't
have more than five people
they did that for me if you're going to
church you can't go to church anymore
right
you can't go to church you can't do
anything you have to stay in your house
but
if you're willing to riot running down
main street if you're willing to riot
and stand on top of each other's face
and do whatever the hell you want to do
you're allowed to do that because you're
considered a peaceful
protester so we decided to call all our
rallies peaceful protests
is he high right now
instead of standing up to the far left
riders biden condemns law enforcement
and condemns america didn't even mention
the words
that we love and respect
law and order you know they're all
telling me even my people my very
brilliant consultants so i don't listen
to
too much maybe i should sir please don't
say law and order
it's too tough now in the meantime you
look at these streets people
crazy they say say law and order
but with safety and with security i said
look people get it
it's just law order is that okay lord we
want law and order
they say lord order and safety sir could
you add the word safety
because it's sir i said i don't want to
it's sort of obvious right we want law
we want order biden is fueling the
violence with his
relentless attacks on police and his
constitution yeah the transitions are
are completely out of control today
almost every police group in the country
sheriffs in florida ohio texas
north carolina all over the country
but did you notice he's starting to talk
a little bit tougher now did you notice
that he sees what's going on his poles
are dropping like a rock and he sees
that's not true now he's starting to say
no we need uh
law daughter no he didn't say that did
he
can't he'll never get to say that can't
say that because then it'd lose the
whole left
and let me tell you the left is running
that party you take a look
you don't want to be dealing with the
left these people are stone cold crazy
you don't want to be dealing
meanwhile biden he doesn't say a word
about the thousands of african-americans
who are murdered each year as a result
of violent crime
in democrat-controlled cities what does
that mean that he doesn't
say anything about it he talks about it
all the time it's just he's not using
the racialized language trump is using
all backgrounds who build up our
communities not the violent criminals of
extremists
and agitators and anarchists
who burn them down next time you
see video of screaming far left maniacs
shouting wildly
at peaceful americans remember this
these are biden supporters
and if he wins they will be that's
almost certainly untrue
the tiny percentage of people that are
being violent are
extremely unlikely to be voting biden in
fact they're more likely to think that
biden and trump are both cut from the
same cloth
or as is written in the nation today
could even be right-wing provocateurs
and there's an investigation going on
into that
we're never gonna give him a chance to
do it we're never giving him a chance
we're gonna win we're gonna win big
this is a very important state and by
the way
and by the way when they send out their
millions and millions of
unsolicited ballots when you get a
ballot say well i wanted to go and vote
darling i wanted to go and vote why are
they sending me those ballots there's
something really
the only way we lose north carolina and
a couple of others like
nevada we're doing great there oh yeah
now the governor decides we're doing so
well that they're going to send out
unsolicited you have solicited and
unsolicited
they're going to send out millions of
ballots
to you people that never really thought
in terms of it
now sometimes you'll ask for a ballot
that's a solicited ballot
it's okay you have to go through a
process you have to sign a form
sending out millions of unsolicited
ballots
make sure you send the ballot in and
then go to your polling place and make
sure it counts
this is illegal because the only way
they can win
is by doing very bad things okay he
actually stopped sort of suggesting to
try to vote a second time okay
so that was not illegal last time he did
it it was a crime you know
it's an airport hi fellas
they did a good job guiding the planet
they're great they're great no
this is an airport if he were honestly i
really
if he had 200 people i think it would be
a lot i really mean do you ever see the
gyms with the circles
that's his crowd if he had two hundred
people
there is a pandemic so we have 15 000
people here tonight
if that's true it's immoral and more
likely it's a lie
but they'll correct it they'll say he's
wrong it was 14
500 he's misrepresented he's
misrepresenting
now i always tell we have 15 000 and
we're in the middle of an airport
someplace
in the middle of a pandemic and you know
i actually think i don't know if you
agree
so we go to the arenas but because of uh
china
the arenas aren't working out too well
right you can't really do that anymore
for a while
but we are rounding the turn i will tell
you we're rounding the turn on that but
because of that
rounding the turns so we said where
because we have the same crowds i think
we have bigger crowds
potentially we were in new hampshire the
other night we had to turn away 8 000
people
at an airport we're doing all mostly
hangar things because we're outside
outside
is very much different than being inside
according to the
great doctors right but they say it's
very much different
so we're doing these and we're doing the
outdoors we're doing that down with doc
i really believe that these crowds are
bigger than they were four years ago
it's
pretty important these people know
they're all nodding pretty amazing not
even covering their noses
we started off in new hampshire we said
look let's have
a thousand people and they had like five
or six show up and they had thousands
more
you know we're trying to be nice but
then eventually we landed
two weeks ago we landed in new hampshire
and the entire runway was lit up with
thousands and thousands of people as the
plane was landing
i don't think that anybody was allowed
on the runway i think that that that's
got to be a lie
right it's a great thing
more support than we had four years ago
because you know four years ago i said i
was going to do this i was going to cut
your taxes i was going to cut
regulations i was going to get right to
try i was going to take care of your
vets
i was going to rebuild your military i
was going to do all these things
and you said you said i don't know
that's a lot of
you know what i've actually done more
than i promised you build a wall
build a wall oh my god
i've done more for instance you never
heard me say
you never heard me say you a lot of you
were at various rallies
you never heard me talking about space
force we built
a new think of it a new branch of the
united states military
united states armed forces called air
force
i never talked about that that's
something we never talked about
because i saw what russia was doing and
what china was doing i said we have to
do the same thing
and if you think that was easy that was
not easy that was not easy it was very
hard
but what we've done you know the wall
now is past 300 miles
last week it was 400. it's exactly the
wall that our great border patrol wanted
i was hoping a nice concrete plank for
the builders in here
boom boom you put it sir we have to be
able to see through i said all right
let's
go much more expensive and i said let's
go
so we're over 300 miles now and we will
be finished with it very soon
yeah and we have at this rate it should
only take 30 more years
bad by far and it's a good time to have
it too
and you know mexico is paying for the
wall just so you understand another
they don't say that they never say it
because they're not going to charge a
small fee at the border
no you know the toll booths we have toe
boats that are never going to happen
better in the world in terms of people
going across and in terms of will not
have believe it or not the southern
border
we're putting a small toll on and maybe
we're going to do something with
remittance that's where people come here
make money and they send it back
oh so we'll do something and we're gonna
that's not gonna work all the money that
we spent in the mall
wall will be coming back so remember i
used to say
who's gonna pay for it they'd say mexico
it was a lie then and it's a lie now
that's right
and what happens if they fight us
remember that answer
it's going to get 10 feet higher
remember that what happens if they fight
us
on the wall the wall's going to get 10
feet higher but now mexico and i get
along great in fact
they have 27 000 soldiers along our
southern border
protecting us from people coming into
our country can you imagine that
so 27 000
and i did that so that we don't put
tariffs on their products coming in it
was very simple i said you got to do it
and
the president's been great he's a friend
of mine he's doing a very good job not
easy
mexico is not easy but he's doing a very
good job
but the wall is almost completed and
it's a tremendous wall it's everything
they've replaced
200 and something miles uh it's almost
done guys
and it's wired for every single thing
you could have remember the democrats we
don't want a wall we want it's wired for
wi-fi
and then even they even you could do an
optical audio cable if you have the
right speakers it's wired for everything
supports cutting police funding and he
has pledged to
end cash bail just last week sleepy joe
proudly accepted the endorsement of the
pro-criminal
anti-police portland district attorney
who has a policy of releasing rioters
vandals criminals and violent extremists
without
charge now last night though they
arrested more than they've ever done
because we said you have to we said you
have to
and we told them about we will
federalize them we'll do whatever you
need
and i spoke to the governor it looks
like they're finally after 107 days like
they're finally doing what they're
supposed to be doing but
we'll let you know very soon otherwise
we're going in
the biden bernie manifesto pledges to
implement these same policies nationwide
the one that's like hey we probably want
to stop fracking soon
a lefty but not as bad as her but a
radical left
and i got a lot of bernie voters i think
15 last time because they agree with me
on trade they understand
that many of these countries including
our so-called allies
are ripping us off they're ripping us
off on trade
i agree with him on that the difference
is i know how to do something about it
they don't they don't have a clue they
just know
they're being ripped off and a lot of
bernie people feel that that's a big
point
and they came over and they voted for me
instead of crooked hillary which was a
very nice thing we appreciate it we hope
we don't lose it
because we've really implemented things
you know we've taken an interesting poll
of non-voters from 2016
non-voters from 2016 planning to vote
two-thirds planning to vote for biden
that's that's a very interesting number
they haven't given us we signed a great
trade deal but the ink wasn't dry when
the plague came in
so i view that trade deal as uh much
differently than i did before much
differently it's a great deal
they just last week they ordered the
biggest order of corn in history
the biggest order of soybeans in history
and i say
just shows you though they're smart very
smart instead of saying you know he's
not talking very nicely about us and
we're not going to order anymore we're
not going to do business no
instead they do the opposite they give
us the biggest orders we've
our farmers are very happy wrong our
farmers are very happy
very very untrue in fact the latest
rasmussen poll a right-wing poll which
has trump losing in ohio
believed partially to be driven by
farmers dollars
because that's what you were targeted
for by china and i gave you 28 out of
the tariffs and we had tens of billions
of dollars left over which went into the
u.s
treasury but nobody's ever done this
before
nobody's ever done this before with
biden it's the reverse
his son goes sits down for 10 minutes
with the father and whoever the hell
they sat down with
walks out with one and a half billion
dollars to manage he'll make millions of
dollars a year
and he has no experience at all never
happened before
biden's plan is to appease the domestic
terrorists my plan is to arrest them
now some of these domestic terrorists
they're not really terrorists they're
just protesters
do what you want vote for the candidate
backed by violent left-wing rioters if
you have to
or do what you want to vote for the
candidate backed by the selfless heroes
of law enforcement and just about
everybody else
when you see the numbers when you see
the number
you know there was a poll that just came
out it was i think it was gallup
and it was a weird kind of a poll
because it said 62
of the people that are polled are lying
that's a big number right i think it was
62 it was a poll
about who's lying and
they're only lying if it's us because
they don't want to be bothered
in other words they're not lying about
sleepy joe they're lying about us
and i don't know if i'm supposed to so
62 of the people not voting for trump
are lying about not voting how does that
my brain is not able to compute this we
have a virtual landslide going
[Applause]
yeah that's so dumb i don't even
understand all of the ways in which it's
idiotic
by some really great friends of mine
representatives
senators just some incredible people
people that have really helped me and we
have to get them in office and let's
start off with senator
tom tillis oh god
he could be out of office soon he's been
by my side
thank you tom very much representatives
greg murphy virginia foxx
mark walker dan bishop and ted budd what
a group
what a group
water group thank you fellas they're
warriors
boy i'll tell you those house guys they
were in there they were
fighting for us we were 196 to nothing
right
when uh crazy nancy impeached us right
they impeached me
for making a phone call that was perfect
it was a perfect call
[Music]
i'll go down as the only president in
history that got impeached for making an
absolutely perfect phone call thank
goodness i had the call because they
totally misrepresented what was on the
call
if you ever heard the shifty shift get
up in congress and say what i said if i
ever said that it would have been
terrible
but you know what fortunately we had
really talented people taking down
everything word for word we had to call
perfectly
and if i didn't have it somehow with
these people i guess i'd still be here
if you want to know that too
but it was a lot easier but we were 196
to nothing the republicans stuck
together
and kevin mccarthy's done a fantastic
job he really has
everybody knows who that is i'm sure
and with the exception of a half a vote
from mitt romney you can have him
he's not too popular i want to tell you
he's not a very popular guy in utah
he's not too popular he's actually
pretty popular he'll he could win easily
re-election
he's uh he's a beauty i'll tell you that
guy he couldn't get elected dog catcher
in utah right now
he just got elected remember utah they
said
it's too close to call this was before
the election no
and then they announced utah the polls
are closed donald trump has won the
state of utah do you remember that like
immediately
i won by a lot and there was some guy
running mcmuffin
mcmuffin that's right mcmuffin he was
supposed to be second even hillary beat
him
what a group lieutenant governor dan
forrest dan oh my god
get out and vote for him get out and
vote for him
okay he'll be a great governor
he loves your state he'll be a great
governor tom is going to be a great
great senator for another six years we
need him both
and i hope you're going to do well dan i
know you're really getting up there it's
getting very close
i'll be honest if this governor
that you have i know him you know we had
to take our convention away
he said you're allowed to have ten
people in the arena ten
because it said one room ten you're not
supposed to have political rallies i
said you know the money that your state
is going to be losing
but if this guy doesn't open up your
state
because almost all of them are open now
if he doesn't open up your state
you have no choice you're going to vote
for him anyway but dan you'll be so
right so good
dan farris go and vote the republican
nominee for north carolina attorney
general
jim o'neill jim
where is jim thank you jim thank you
very much
good luck got to be careful with those
ballots watch those ballots
i don't like it you know you have a
democrat governor you have all these
democrats watching that stuff
i don't like it i look at these crowds
and if they're going to cheat crowds are
meaningless really
if they're going to cheat well crowds
are meaningless voting is what matters
18
000 you could have 50 000 these crowds
are meaningless watch it
be pole watches when you go there watch
all the thieving and
stealing and robbing thieving because
this is important we win north carolina
burglary at the polls my friends
pickpockets and north carolina
republican party chairman
michael watley great
thank you michael thank you great job
and a very good friend of mine a great
guy mick
mulvaney where's mick oh
i didn't know mick was here look at him
what a good guy thank you mick okay
well we have a lot of big big shots over
there i see but what do you think about
a guy named
mark meadows chief of staff
disgusting we love mark
please he's doing a great job
robert o'brien robert how many how
many hostages have you and i negotiated
to get back
not giving anything but we haven't i
thought he was going to say how many
have we taken
50 50 you know we're 50-00 hostages we
got him back
we got hostages back from countries that
you never even heard of
certainly countries trump hasn't heard
of anyway thank you all for being here
mick it's good to see you
oh wait a minute wait it's a very very
outstanding senator oh i'm lucky i got
to see that
does everybody do we love south carolina
right oh no don't tell me tim scott's
there
come here linda g graham
everybody lindsey graham even worse
even worse lindsey and tim scott two
great ones
two great ones they may be from a
different state but they love you
lindsay that's good
and tim is another one so we have just
incredible people in the party we've
achieved more in four years than anyone
ever thought possible and that's driving
them crazy
more destruction we passed massive tax
cuts
like nobody ever thought was possible
for hard-working families
and we eliminated a record number of
job-killing regulations more than
any president in history whether it was
four years eight years or in one case
more regulations
and to keep family farms in the family
we eliminated the unfair estate tax also
known as the death tax right
on your small farms and businesses right
which affected like the tiniest sliver
of the richest of the rich
i think people were fighting for that
your family lost the farm lost their
small business because they had to go
and pay this ridiculous estate tax or
debt taxes they call it
and now you don't have to worry about it
if you love your children
you leave it to them if you don't leave
love your children then
it doesn't matter what i did don't leave
it to them give it to charity give it
this help no
if they're not good to you if you don't
love but does anybody here not love
their children
please raise your hand you
okay trump should raise this nobody good
i love that that's oh look at that one
you're gonna love that one i guarantee
you
i guarantee you're gonna love that one
that's a keeper
that's a keeper right
that's great you'll love that one
someday in a long time from now
that beautiful child will not have to
worry about estate taxes unless the
democrats do something in between
no but it was a terrible thing you'd
pass away and your kids would get
the farm they'd go out borrow a lot of
money because the estate tax was
massive they'd put big mortgages on the
farm they'd lose the farm
they'd lose the business you don't have
that anymore i saved the
u.s auto industry by withdrawing from
the last administration's job-killing
catastrophe
the trans-pacific partnership was a
disaster
for half a century joe biden
shook hands with blue-collar workers and
then he
turned around and immediately stabbed
them in the back
biden supported nafta china's entry into
the world trade organization
tpp the south korea disaster deal
and mass amnesty for illegal aliens
think of it but but the big news
he's changed he's changed after 47 years
i've changed i swear to you i've changed
it's funny because trump claims that at
age 68 he stopped being in favor of
abortion
right before he ran for president and
yet he wants us to believe
biden couldn't change in 40 years but
trump changed after 68.
everything they want free health care
for people to come into the country
illegally
colleges everything now the new deal
under the new deal they get lawyers if
they come
in to our country illegally we supply
them with legal advice
you believe it lawyers this is what we
need is more lawyers
this state lost 43 percent of all
manufacturing jobs after the twin
disasters of nafta and china's entrance
into the world trade organization that's
courtesy of biden
and his friends earlier this year i kept
my promise to north carolina
when we ended the nafta nightmare and we
signed the brand new u.s
mexico canada agreement into law been
incredible
everyone said impossible they all said
it was impossible to get done we got it
done
and it's a great deal and it prevents
people it prevents companies from
fleeing your state opening up in mexico
or canada
making a product selling it to us with
it's such a disincentive to do that now
that was the thing that was most
important to me i used to hate when i
see all these companies
leaving our country going to mexico in
particular but canada also a lot of them
going to canada
and they'd make a product everybody gets
fired in our country they close their
business and they make the same product
in a different country they send it back
to us no tax
at the border no tariff no nothing it
doesn't work that way anymore
i took the toughest ever action to stand
up
to china's pillaging plundering
ransacking and rampant theft
of north carolina jobs and u.s jobs
joe biden's agenda is made in china my
agenda is made in the usa
wow powerful right
in the face of china's economic
aggression we provided a historic 28
billion dollars in relief to our amazing
farmers
i will always stand with american
agriculture these are the greatest
people the finest people
and we're not going to let others take
advantage of them
you know for 20 years for 20 years you
look at a chart
it's just been this way for 20 years now
it's going back up
i mean it helped that i gave you 28
billion dollars in all fairness
right people i didn't do that and i took
it all from china it was very easy
if i didn't do that i think you wouldn't
have any farmers right now really
there was a difference between having
farmers that are doing well and having
no farmers 28 billion over two years
they got
hit one year 16 billion one year 12
billion i said to sonny perdue secretary
of
agriculture great guy an ex-farmer
governor of georgia for eight years
great guy i said sonny how much are they
being targeted for
he said sir 12 12 billion dollars
sir for the year before and last year
sir it was
16 so i said 28 okay that's fine
i said we will give them 28 billion they
were unfairly targeted
and that was in order to get me and by
the way china wants joe biden so badly
oh
they want you know who else would like
them very badly iran would like them
very badly who does russia want
because i ended that iran catastrophe
that we paid 150 billion and
1.8 billion in cash and you know what's
going to happen they're just waiting for
the election because the country is
going down the tubes
their gdp went down 24 nobody ever heard
of that before
their country is in trouble ours was
down 32
last quarter they're gonna wait until
after the election
when i win the election they're going to
come to us and make a deal so
fast
watch how fast it'll be they're dying to
make a deal but they do want to wait
let's wait two months maybe we'll get
lucky maybe we're going to get lucky and
slow joe gets in and
we're going to make a great deal no
they'll be they'll be in
immediately after the election and
they'll make a deal we'll make a fair
deal with them
but what obama did and biden did with
that horrible iran deal
i ended last administration's war on
american energy
biden has pledged to end production of
american oil shale
clean coal no fracking that's correct
wiping out millions of jobs and forcing
us to buy energy from more like
replacing
we don't want to buy energy we've done
that for a long time for decades and
decades we don't want to do that anymore
i like being energy independent don't
you
and i'm sure that most some people
noticing the crowd is bored i agree
although it's hard to tell just from
this section of the crowd but they are
much quieter
i do think these just go way too long
especially when you consider how
how much earlier people need to get
there i think these are way too long
and just very poorly put together
and look at your electric bills
everything else these guys your electric
would go up four five
six times the green new deal it's called
the green new nightmare
we're almost 50 minutes in and you can
tell trump is nowhere near done
we'll remain the number one producer of
oil and natural gas on earth
and we will remain energy independent
it should be for many many years to come
because the fact is we don't have to be
in the middle east other than we want to
protect israel we've been very good to
israel
but other than that we don't have to be
in the middle east we don't need you
know there was a time we needed
desperately or we don't need that
anymore
we have more than they do isn't that
nice after years of rebuilding other
countries
we are finally building our country
america first it's america first
to bring hope to our inner cities i
created opportunity zones i worked with
senator tim scott of south carolina
what a great guy he has passed criminal
justice reform
prison reform delivered permanent
funding for historically black colleges
and universities that obama never did
or couldn't do and biden
i call it oh biden oh biden it's too
long to say obama and but
just call it obiden right
and before the china virus we achieved
the lowest african-american hispanic
american asian-american unemployment
rates
ever recorded hey so can it what's the
reason trump is
making what's the case trump is making
here for why someone should vote for him
i'm not even sure i understand it
american voters he betrayed them look at
1994.
take a look at that he betrayed them
what he did to them
he closed the factories in baltimore and
sent them to beijing
they were all sent to beijing so many
people went there
they went to all parts of the world but
a lot went to beijing
he shuddered the plants in chicago and
sent them to shanghai
unlike the previous administration
under my administration we put america
[Music]
first
and actually if we weren't interrupted
with constant
investigations that went nowhere and
nobody has been through what i've been
through as president of the united
states nobody pesky
you know they used to say abraham
lincoln got the worst press i said
there's no way he got worse than me
but lincoln was very very badly treated
by the fake news
maybe in his case it was real i can tell
you in my case it's fake
it's totally fake but nobody's been and
it should never be allowed to happen
again let's see what happens we caught
them cold let's see what happens
but if we didn't have to you know that
takes time and energy and all of the
things the time that we spent on this
impeachment hoax nancy pelosi with her
hair dryer and the whole thing
everybody has to wear a mask you must
keep all beauty parlors closed
since she's in a beauty bottle with no
mask oh
and then she said the the biggest the
biggest fish she could have said okay
she said you got me but she said i got
set up by the beauty parlor owner who
happens to be a trump person by the way
she said i got set up by the owner of
the beauty parlor now
set me up i said how are you going to do
with putin kim jong-un and president xi
of china
no it's terrible she's always preaching
about the mask you've got to wear the
mask at all times indoor outdoor
when you go to bed at night put the mask
on
i've spent the last four years keeping
my promises
and delivering for the african-american
community and when i'm
re-elected the best is yet to come i'll
tell you
[Applause]
perhaps in no area have our opponents
more thoroughly betrayed working
families
of all backgrounds than on the subject
of
immigration uh-oh under my
administration we've achieved the most
secure border in american history
now i have to tell you that 300 miles of
wall helps a lot
[Music]
[Applause]
they don't work really i always say
and i've said it four or five times i'll
say it again if you'd like me to
two things if you come back in a
thousand years two thousand years or
3000 years
if you're lucky enough assuming we have
something with with the world as a crazy
place isn't it
but if you come back in a thousand years
there are two things with all the
computers and all the everything changes
every day
you invent a new cell you invent a new
laptop
everything is obsolete like about two
weeks after you invented right
two things that will never get obsolete
the wall
and the wheel right and he's taken
responsibility for both
maybe i'm wrong who knows but i would
say walls
and wheels have a great future we ended
catch and release
stopped asylum fraud and we've deported
20
000 gang members including the radical
ms-13 we invested 2.5 trillion dollars
in the united states military all
made in the usa by the way
[Applause]
we have the newest finest military week
so remember there were people falling
all over themselves yesterday to say oh
trump criticized the military industrial
complex he said the pentagon doesn't
like him because they want to just do
wars to get
bombs purchased he's bragging about
buying the bombs okay don't fall for it
satisfaction with the va has just
reached
91 the highest satisfaction level
in history
i withdrew from the last
administration's disastrous iran nuclear
deal as i said and i kept my promise
and recognized the true capital of
israel and
opened the united states embassy in
jerusalem
and then i recognized israeli
sovereignty over the golan heights
and we achieved the first breakthrough
in the middle east piece
for many many decades decades even the
new york times said that was an amazing
achievement you believe that
i said let me see that one no we did
something that nobody thought was
possible
and it's israel as you see and as you've
read
israel and uae highly respected leader
muhammad highly highly respected and now
we have other countries in the middle
east they all want to come in it's going
to be a beautiful picture
going to be a beautiful picture
we killed the vicious founder and leader
of isis
al baghdadi we killed him
why didn't biden get him you know they
were after him for eight years they
never got him i got him
the world's number one terrorist and the
mass murderer of
american troops kasim salamani
still can't say it huh salamani
[Applause]
al baghdadi and salamani the two worst
terrorists in the world for many many
years many decades
we kept america out of new wars and
we're bringing our troops back home
we're bringing them back home
from all these far away places
[Applause]
we spend hundreds of billions of dollars
and what do we get out of it
biden voted for the iraq war he
supported the defense sequester that
gutted our military
he opposed the mission to take out osama
bin laden
so you know they've been i mean those
are all lies but the bin laden thing
there was a point where biden said
we should be more sure before we go
forward and trump tries to frame it as
if he was like no we shouldn't even go
after osama bin laden
but the crowd doesn't know that they
don't know that
and you saw the mueller family on
television you saw that at the
convention
what al baghdadi did with
their beautiful daughter and uh
incredible how our troops handled that
you should see it it was incredible
biden also cheered
the rise of china as a positive
development
positive development for america and for
the world how we doing with china we
just
have the plague i mean listen the truth
is obviously we have adversarial
elements of our relationships but if you
have an economy based on
cheap stuff and outsourcing the rise of
china
benefits that strategy you could argue
we shouldn't have that strategy but
that's
the strategy that has been the strategy
here for decades guy that doesn't know
where he is
i can't believe it when i banned travel
from china biden called it hysterical
and xenophobic do you remember that i
banned it
everybody told me no no no you don't
have to do that but i said
this lady remembers is very infected and
they're coming here so i banned it or
this guy out there
said to be a great move if we had
listened to joe hundreds of thousands
more americans would have died
if biden wins china will own america and
it won't take long
with his son hunter walking out with all
of that money with no
experience whatsoever no investment he
didn't even have a job
joe biden is weak and will always cave
to china
who is strong when the virus arrived we
launched the largest
national mobilization since world war ii
we're delivering life-saving therapies
and we have achieved some of the great
numbers the case fatality rates
we have the lowest of any major country
in the world people don't know that
because the fake news doesn't want to
write about it under
operation warp speed we're producing a
vaccine in record time
this is a vaccine that we're going to
have very soon very very soon
by the end of the year but much sooner
than that perhaps
weird that you need a vaccine for
something that's going to go away 15
cases going to zero
by the last administration and in all
fairness by most other administrations
we have upped it to a level that nobody
even
believes is possible and totally safe
joe biden and
kamala harris rated the most liberal
still undermining science and risking
countless lives with their reckless
anti-vaccine rhetoric that's what
they're talking about
so now they know we have it it's only a
question of weeks or a small amount of
time
so instead of saying that's a great
thing we're going to save lives they're
trying to disparage it
no what kamala harris very clearly said
was not anti-vaxx and she said
it's not about the vaccine it's i don't
take anything on trump's word
trump lies all the time so we're not
gonna assume a vaccine is safe
merely because trump or his flunkies say
it that's the point and that's a good
point to make
it out getting it out and we're going to
get it out fast
the vaccine will be safe these are the
greatest companies in the world that do
this the greatest labs the greatest
doctors it'll be effective
and it'll be delivered before the end of
the year
and maybe as i said much sooner than
that joe biden's plan
to impose a blanket shutdown would
collapse our economy and cause countless
deaths from suicide
biden hasn't said that he would impose a
blanket shut down he would say if we
need a national mass
mandate he would do it and if the
situation gets completely out of control
he would consider a shutdown now
remember
it's up to governors and by january 20th
the situation will be dramatically
different i don't think we will be
talking about total shutdowns by january
20th that's just me
what are you doing you don't know what
you're doing they're hurting
hurting our people
north carolina has to open up
by contrast my administration is
following the science protecting those
at highest risk while allowing those
at lower risk to safely return to work
into school go back to school
go back to school
you ever see the statistics on young
people i don't know they just
they have a great immune system let's
get some of that immune system but
they're amazing i mean thousands and
thousands of
people and they're not even affected
very little
meaning of a small percentage of one
percent
it's an incredible thing nobody knew
that when it first came here nobody
assumed a thing like that was possible
but young people are very strong against
this horrible disease
through our historic china virus relief
programs we've saved more than 1.3
million jobs for north carolina workers
that worked out great we provided 380
million dollars in relief for north
carolina farmers
and leaders made 10 million dollars in
people i start to hope that it's ending
and then he goes back to the prompter
after his rants and it's just such a
disappointment
very much in our sights we want to help
them
the biden agenda would crush this
comeback and put our families in grave
danger
biden is promising to reimpose
job-destroying
regulations we got rid of more
regulations
he wants to put those regulations back
plus
50 percent you couldn't build a road we
took roads
from 18 19 and even 20 years approval
down
biden wants to double plus the
regulations for a highway or a for a
road
but you're gonna know in the period of
12 months to 24 months
you're not going to spend an entire
lifetime and then have them raise their
hand
i know all about it from the real estate
business this couple is so bored right
here
he wants to give illegal aliens
government health care and
taxpayer-funded lawyers
establish a national sanctuary city
policy
for illegal aliens with criminal records
you wouldn't believe i mean this stuff
is not even really believable but
it is what it is he wants to search
refugee admissions by 700
into our country flooding your towns
with poorly vetted migrants
including many from jihadist regions of
the world jihadist
biden opposes school choice he opposes
north carolina opportunity scholarships
and he has stated that if he is elected
charter schools are gone he said they're
gone
and they've been incredible obviously
that is not true
provide school choice to every parent in
america
jihadists was interesting we'll also
take good care of our teachers our
teachers are very very important to me
very important nothing more important
a vote for republicans is a vote for
safe communities great jobs
i like how this guy switched positions
with the woman i presume as his wife
next thing you know he'll just be he'll
just leave he'll just go off screen all
together we will make america into the
manufacturing superpower of the world
and we will end our reliance on china
once and for all we'll make our medical
supplies right here in the united states
[Applause]
we will enact fair trade deals that
create american jobs and grow american
wages
we are going to bring our companies back
home where they should be and i've been
doing a lot of it
but we are going to do it at a level
that nobody ever thought possible
the guy is moved on to showing his wife
memes now on his phone
record prosperity we will hire more
police
increase penalties for assaults on law
enforcement
surge federal prosecutors into high
crime
communities and ban all sanctuary
cities bannon
we will protect government benefits for
american citizens
not for illegal aliens what you're doing
when you have all of these advantages
when you're giving them free health care
and free lawyers and free college and
free everything
they all come they didn't think of
coming but they see this they talk and
they talk to their friends
and they all come in they want to come
to america you're just bringing people
in
and we don't want to do that we want
people to come to our country but they
have to come in through merit and they
have to come in legally
very simple
we will appoint prosecutors judges and
justices who believe in enforcing the
law
not their own political agenda we will
ensure equal justice for citizens
of every race color religion and creed
we will defend the dignity of work and
the sanctity of life
right trump's very against abortion now
thanks carter for the raid on twitch
appreciate it welcome everybody
you keep and bear arms
we will strike down terrorists to
threaten our citizens and we will keep
america out of endless ridiculous
foreign wars
foreign wars domestic wars are a
different story
like it's never been built up before we
need our military for other reasons
we will have the strongest we have now
when i took over our military was
depleted we have a lot of military
people here
our military real strong critique of the
military-industrial complex huh guys
we have brand new beautiful f-35s we
have brand new rockets and missiles
hopefully we never have to use them i
will say that
but the best way of not having to use
them is to have them if you have them we
learned that in the school yards right
[Music]
we learned that in the schoolyards the
best way is to have them we have the
strongest military we've ever had by far
will end surprise medical billing
require price transparency which i've
already signed into law which by the way
kicks in on january 1st
you better elect me north carolina
i did price transparency
and i've cut the price drugs are going
to start going down at levels nobody's
ever seen favored nations
[Applause]
imagine listening to this stuff and
believing it
[Applause]
so he did price transparency kicks in
january first could you imagine if this
guy's president and your prices start go
way down hospitalization doctors you can
choose your own doctor
unlike with obama right price is going
way down
under obama someone called me and said
david
you think you like your doctor your
doctor is gone we are telling you who
your doctor is
it was a horrible morning when i got
that call
he would have never done it they gave me
a kid like literally an 11 year old
drug i'm instituting favored nations
losses so
we're going to pay what other nations
pay at the lowest
end and you're going to get back rebates
that we were given to middlemen who have
to be the richest people in the world
we'll protect medicare and social
security we will protect your social
security
and we will always protect patients with
pre-existing conditions always
always america will land the first woman
on the moon in the united states will be
the first nation to land an astronaut on
mars
i found it funny how he's doing this
space travel stuff when it's not been a
priority at all and and
many writers think nasa's a waste of
money now all of a sudden trump is on
mars
the number one space center in the world
by far
by far you see what's going on there you
see what's going on we will restore
patriotic education to our schools
oh you know what i'm talking about i
wish i knew look at you
this is a very sophisticated group tom
you know what i'm talking about
patriotic education this group is
sophisticated guys
they read theory well the first thing
they do is they want to take your
history away
[Applause]
that's a great group behind me i don't
know
they're activists
no but you know what you know what it
means they want to take away your
history that's why the
monuments and the statues they want to
knock them down the first thing they do
is take away
it's weird because germany doesn't have
statues
of nazis but they very much understand
the history they know the history
they've somehow figured out a way to do
it without the statues i don't know how
they've done it
you know what they started off with
generals and colonels and others that
nobody ever heard of and i thought that
was bad
and then they went up a little bit and
all said you know someday it's going to
be robert e lee someday it's going to be
washington
someday it's going to be lincoln someday
it's going to be jefferson
someday it's going to be benjamin
franklin it's all of them
it's all of them they take away your
past they're never taken away our past
then never take it away okay
if that's the way they do it you study
it that's the way they go they take away
your guts
and we'll teach our children to love our
country honor our history
the way your guts like disembowel people
that's horrible flag
and we will live by the timeless words
of our national motto
in god we trust
they yeah the royal
should probably wrap
this is better than the arenas i have to
say
especially when you have a crowd like
this but they're like this they have
such spirit in this country
people love our country so much i went
to texas i went to ohio went to florida
it's always it's always like this they
love they love
our country and we're not going to
disappoint anybody we're not
disappointed
for years you had a president who
apologized for america
[Applause]
wow this is a real cult
check out my interview with stephen
hassan about how the
the this is now a cult and you can see
it right here
i don't feel this way about politicians
i like even i mean this is just not this
is not a healthy relationship to elected
officials
for the people of north carolina
this is the most important election in
the history of our country and i
wouldn't say that lightly and frankly i
thought the last one was
and i said it but they've gone to a
level that nobody even thought possible
these people have gone stone
cold crazy and you know what after we
get in we're gonna have tremendous
success
and it was building we were what does
that mean after we get in
he's in now i i had a commentary last
week that trump's running like someone
else has been president for the last
at least six months what does that mean
when we get in
starting success brings people together
it was so good
our jobs numbers were so good and
whether
whether it was the black community the
hispanic community
the asian community our jobs were so
good our numbers were so good
there was no we were getting together
and then the play came in and we had to
stop
we had to close it up we had to open it
and start all over again
and you know if you would have told me
that we have one of the highest stock
markets some of the stock markets have
already broken
every record you look at nasdaq you look
at some
we have we're far ahead of what i had
planned we're far ahead of the atlanta
but we did it once we have to do it
again because how long ago did he plan
this for us i wonder
at the terrible event a horrible event
so many people died
nobody should have died not one person
so many people died
but if we didn't do it right we would
have been we would have lost millions
of people millions of people and uh
just a terrible thing but oftentimes i
say bring people together and then i
realized
if you look at that last few months we
were starting to come together i was
getting calls from you won't believe it
democrats
i was getting calls from democrats and
they were sort of saying wow things are
going really well
it was starting to happen and now we
have to get it back to a level of great
success
because it'll happen again there'll be
great unity eventually there'll be great
unity
[Music]
so get your friends and get your family
get your neighbors and your co-workers
back to the script
and i say this because it's from
charlotte
to kitty hawk from durham to asheville
and from wilmington to right here in
winston-salem
we inherit the legacy of north carolina
patriots
oh boy gave their blood sweat and tears
for this beloved nation
we stand on the shoulders of american
heroes who cross the oceans
blaze the trails settle the continent
tame the wilderness really as a world
war ii panama canal
laid down the railroads revolutionized
industry won two world wars
defeated fascism and communism and made
america the single greatest nation in
the history of the world
and we are making it greater than ever
before
it's got to be the rap right proud and
great citizens like you helped build
this country
and together we are taking back our
country we are returning power to you
the american people
with your help your devotion and your
drive
we are going to keep on working we are
going to keep on fighting
and we are going to keep on winning
winning
winning oh not that again
we are one movement one people one
family
and one glorious nation under god
glorious and together
with the incredible people of north
carolina
we will make america wealthy again oh no
we will make america strong again he
just needs four more years to do it
we will make america proud again
couldn't do it in the first four we will
make america
safe again taken longer than he hoped
and we
will make america great again
thank you north carolina
wow a disturbingly raucous atmosphere
filled with a guy sitting motionless
and the woman on her phone looking at
memes as you can see
enthusiasm sky high for another four
years of donald trump
uh beyond parody impossible to satirize
saturday night live out of jobs as a
result of oh my goodness he's dancing
um as a result of these uh these events
hey guys let's get to a million youtube
subscribers right now
we've got the people watching we're only
8 000 away
let's do it let's get to a million
youtube subscribers right now why not
consider yourselves invited
uh as donald trump it's really a party
when ymca starts and trump starts
gingerly walking down the steps that is
how you know it is time to party
there it is mouthing kisses and thank
yous to people
um yeah
there it is there's the trump dance it's
sort of like if you had a rope
and you were moving it back and forth
this is the trump dance
uh it is it is quite a dance if i've
ever seen one before
let's just listen a little bit i know
we're gonna hit get hit with copyright
but i just have to hear it
i think it makes more sense with this
song actually today i'm pleased to
make a truly historic announcement in
our battle against the
china virus that will save countless
lives
[Music]
battling a current
[Music]
all right anyway you guys get it so
there there it is donald trump
i guess making the wow people really in
the chat responding to that song
um very much uh
very much making the case for his
reelection on the basis that
he's gonna do things once he gets into
power now you might be saying hasn't he
been in power for four years
that's what i thought that's what i
thought
uh it seems they are it's funny it looks
like they are putting donald trump
in a car to go over the few hundred feet
to the uh plane
trump on his way in ridiculing the idea
that he wouldn't of course walk over
and now indeed they are putting him in a
car to get back to his
airplane it appears listen thank you to
everybody for joining me
we did it we got 64 new members
our initial goal was only 25
we are rapidly uh
50 000 followers on twitch and of course
rapidly rapidly approaching 1 million
youtube subscribers thank you so much
i will see everybody very very soon
china virus that will save countless
lives
we provided 48 million dollars to fund
the mayo clinic study that tested
[Music]
this is
convalescent was